sind wir hier in einem schummrigen
nachtleben oder befinden wir uns
lichtjahre entfernt in fremden galaxien
weit gefehlt wir sind dem herzstück des
toni areal im orgelsaal schwarz ist es
hier
hochglänzend daniel niggli vom
architekturbüro m2m will mit diesem raum
das image der orgel aufpolieren
kratzer staub alles gewollte patina mit
der linie stets forsch plastischer nicht
der klassische relativ rasch stellt aber
so dass es alle gebrauchsspuren du dein
ruhm abbruch es ist fasziniert ist so
die symbiose zwischen radler und ruhm
es ist so das instrument der ruhm ist
und mir auch so ziert normal ist auch
klasse stark mit dem sakralen raum mit
thriller und umsatz interessiert mit
einer demontage hatten angaben soll das
instrument zu sein anders erschienen ist
die verschieden großen schwarzen plastik
elemente sorgen für akustischen
hochgenuss und ein lichtspiel das sich
immer wieder verändert
doch der innenausbau stieß bei tobias
willi orgelprofessor hier im haus
anfangs auf skepsis
das historisches thema also eigentlich
kirchliche musik wo gar nicht zu ihnen
passt vor eigentlichen kathedrale bruch
die rundum und ich stehe sei aber wie
gut dass das klingt der akustik vor dem
saarland auf dem instrument und er ist
hier der hausherr michael benz chef des
departements musik der größten abteilung
an der zhdk orgel studenten jedoch sind
hier
keine 25 sind es mit den kirchenmusikern
ist der pompöse so etwas wie ein letztes
aufbäumen bevor die orgel stirbt in
stand ich ganz sicher und ich will
meiner die hat ziemlich viel
zukunftsträchtige potenzial was aber
tatsächlich der fall ist in ganz europa
ist das leidet nachfrage nach einem
studium zusehends druck
es hat mit kulturellen anderes tun mit
der schule fern heid von ihrer jugend
wobei man muss nicht fromm sie zum wohl
der spieler dass ich nun jesus sie
besitzt da alles auch solcher weil es
noch nicht kennen
eidenbenz ist selber begeisterter
organist genügt die strahlkraft des
spektakulären saals aber um den
nachwuchs hierher zu ziehen
die punkte ich das meiner muss in vielen
oder zonen rohr geführt werden und mir
sind für die mittelschulen oder wo immer
das kann passieren dass findet immer
weniger stadt rund 9000 arbeitsstunden
stecken im innern dieser orgel der chef
des luzerner orgelbauers gold simon
heben hat das instrument entwickelt
musikhochschule instrument das ich sehr
erzogen doch im normalfall mit cleo
kretschmer wo man natürlich viel
größeres volumen hell und hier geht es
immer um die für sich nach langen fahrt
könnte also darf nichts mit weder wo wir
mehr gestritten das plenum also kann es
vorwärts spielt mit allen registern
bedarf das eben nicht erschlagen sagen
1671 orgelpfeifen sind hier verarbeitet
36 register sorgen für die verschiedenen
klangfarben aus zwetschgen ebenholz und
marzahn sind die drei manuale
die ästhetik der orgel klassisch
das design des saals gewöhnungsbedürftig
moment lieber bis sie wieder dabei
er tönt die orgel fühlte sich ja immer
noch an wie in der kirche
und trotzdem ist der saal eine perle der
schwarze perlen